The three things that I want to leave
with you,
just these three.
I could do 10 I could do a whole life
class,
but just these three things will carry
you if you let them.
First and foremost,
knowing who you are,
being able to answer this question,
who am I and what do I want?
You know,
many times when I go out of the country,
I am baffled by that question to explain
what is your occupation?
I've I've stood there for 10 minutes.
Well,
am I talk show hosts?
I'm more than a talk show hosts and my
business woman,
I'm business woman more than a business
woman.
Am I an entrepreneur more than do her,
so I just leave it blank or self
employed.
So I'm not asking for the roles that you
play as daughters.
I'm not asking that question.
What are the roles that you play as a
daughter,
as a friend,
as a sister?
You're going to be a lawyer,
you're going to teach,
you're going to be a pharmacist.
I'm asking the bigger question of who am
I?
Who am I really?
My answer is I am God's child.
I am.
I am that which is born of all that is I
am as shot and said,
a spiritual being,
having a human experience come trailing
the breadth of the ancestors yet,
but trailing the breadth of the angels
and understanding that because I am
connected to the source of all that is
all that is possible is possible for me.
That's who I am and what do I want.
I don't want to just be successful in
the world.
I don't want to just make a mark or have
a legacy.
The answer to that question for me is I
want to fulfill the highest,
truest expression of myself as a human
being.
I want to fulfill the promise that the
creator dreamed when he dreamed the
cells that made up me.
What do I want?
You must have some kind of vision for
your life.
Even if you don't know the plan,
you have to have a direction in which
you choose to go.
I never was the kind of woman who liked
to get in a car and just go for a ride.
I had a boyfriend would say,
let's just go for a ride.
I want to know where we go.
We
do we have a destination.
Is there a plan or we just ride.
What I've learned is that to great
metaphor for life,
you want to be in the driver's seat of
your own life because if you're not,
life will drive you.
So
knowing who you really are in this space
in time that we embody,
that's number one.
What do you want?
Who are you?
Number two,
you must find a way to serve.
Martin Luther King said that not
everybody can be famous,
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service.
Now we live in a world where everybody
wants to be famous and where we admire
people for just being famous,
we think being known brings us value.
The truth is all of that will fade in
time in three years.
You won't be able to name the housewives
of Atlanta.
The real truth is that service and
significance service and the
significance that you bring to your
service is that which is lasting.
So to be able to whatever your
occupation or job or talent or gift is.
Our honorees today,
getting doctorate degrees too,
apparently opposite fields,
HIV and aids and the spoken word,
but what they have in common is service
using the spoken word in service to
community and the world using your
knowledge and information about HIV and
AIDS and medicine in service to the
world and if you look at all the most
successful people in the world,
whether they know it or not,
they have that paradigm of service.
Everybody's talking about Mark
Zuckerberg and IPO
service,
Jay z rapid service through the word to
people through song.
For many years I was really just happy
to be on TV and people would stop and
say,
Oh,
you on tv?
Yeah,
I'm on TV.
I like being on TV.
It's a nice job
and was about the time that I received
my honorary doctorate from spelman
around 1993 so I don't know if that had
something to do with it.
I thought of myself as Doctor Winfrey.
Then I went back and I took a long look
at what it was I was doing on on TV and
made a decision that I was no longer
going to just be on tv,
but I was going to use TV as a platform,
as a force for good and not be used by
TV.
And I will tell you
my decision to make that significant
change in the way I operated on
television using television as a service
changed my career exponentially service
through medicine.
So service through art,
using whatever it is you produce your
product as a way of giving back to the
world.
When you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do to service and
you bring significance to that,
success will,
I promise you,
follow you.
Service and significance equals success.
That's number two.
Number three.
It's so simple but so hard to do.
Always do the right thing.
Always
be excellent.
People notice,
think of how you notice.
You go to Taco Bell,
somebody gives you extra napkin and some
sauce.
You notice you want to go back to that
person.
Cause even at Taco bell excellence shows
itself.
Be Excellent.
Let excellence be your brand.
Everybody talks about building a brand.
I never even knew what that was.
When people would say,
you are a brand,
I would say no,
I'm just oprah.
What I recognize now is that my choice
to it every way in every example,
in every experience to do the right
thing.
And the excellent thing is what has
created the brand.
Years ago I did an ad for Revlon for uh,
for uh,
an ad,
uh,
they were doing called unforgettable
women.
And what I know is that when you are
excellent,
you become unforgettable.
People remember you,
you stand out.
We got us of what it is.
You become an unforgettable woman.
And that is what we all want.
We want to be unforgettable and not
forgettable.
So doing the right thing,
even when nobody knows you're doing the
right thing,
we'll always bring the right thing to
you.
I promise you that.
Why?
Because the third law of motion is
always at work.
For every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction.
That is so true in all of our lives.
That's what Newton said,
Celia and the color purple said it.
Everything you even try to do that
all ready done to you
Britt
thing you even tried to do to me already
done to you so you don't have to worry
about revenge or getting back at
somebody,
making sure they pay.
You just have to do the right thing and
the right thing.
We'll follow you even when people don't
support it.
I remember many times on my shelf,
there are many shows y'all never saw and
the reason you didn't see them is
because I got the last boat and I
remember 2010 my team,
hardest working team in television had
done this interview with a woman who
turns out she was a Sunday school
teacher by day and a sex addict ignite.
Ooh.
They were like,
you won't believe in.
We got her going out.
We got her with the men and we get to
show her and she was willing to show us
if ref Fang.
I sat down with a woman for an interview
that was taped and during the process of
the interview I said,
why are you doing this?
And she said,
oh,
I want to help people.
I want to tell my story and I want to
help people.
I said,
do you have children?
She says,
yes,
I have a 10 year old son.
I knew right then this is never going to
see the light of day.
So we got off the air and I said to the
lady,
we are not going to air that show.
And she said,
why?
My producer said,
why she knew she was being filmed.
She knew what she was saying.
She knows what I said because her son
will never get over it.
Her son will never get over it and it's
not worth a rating point to me,
not worth the rating point to me to know
that there's a 10 year old boy who's
destroyed because his mother went on the
Oprah Winfrey show and told all her
business,
you do the right thing even when other
people think it may not be.
And oftentimes when you make a decision
to do the right thing,
immediately you're faced with doubt.
Was that the right thing?
Was that the right decision?
I don't know.
Was that the right thing?
You always know it's the right thing.
When in the end there is peace.
You are rewarded by peace and knowing
that you did the right thing.
The most important thing I have come to
know in doing the right thing and making
the right choices is understanding
what we talked about yesterday.
All of you leaving here have the
potential for enormous success.
There's a price that comes with that.
People don't always like you
and they're not always happy for you,
and if you surround yourself with people
who are not accustomed to your success,
they become fearful.
They become scared because you are
reflecting back something to them,
but they don't recognize.
Now they're not going to say,
you know,
I'm very fearful,
okay,
because you were reflecting back to me
something I don't recognize.
They're going to say,
you know what they're going to say.
They're going to say who she thinks she
is,
who she thinks she is.
That only happens when you are around
people who do not mean and want and
aspire to the best for you people who
want the best for you.
I want you to be your best.
So my greatest advice to you is to
surround yourself with people who are
going to fill your cup until your cup
runneth over.
So when people say you're so full of
yourself,
you can say,
yeah,
yes,
Oh,
I'm so full,
my cup runneth over.
And to know that once you're a cup
runneth over,
you cannot spend your life with your
gallon size offerings offering them to
pint size people.
You have got to surround yourself with
size people who can hang in the same
company with you so that you're not
offering your gallons to those little
pipes out there who can't hold it
anyway,
choice to change the world.
I love that song.
I love hearing you all sing that song
and what I know for sure is that the
biggest choices begin and in with you,
your internal big questions.
Who do I want to be in the world?
My relationship to source energy to all
that is God.
I'm not talking about what you believe
in God.
I'm talking about your experience of
that which is all life,
which is divine and universal.
I'm talking about the big deal,
being connected and aligned with that.
When you are tuned in and charged into
that,
whenever you feel empty,
you go inside yourself and you connect
to the source and you know that all
things are possible
to know that
and to choose to do the right thing in
service and significance.
I promise you,
you will create a vessel of service for
yourself first because you have to honor
yourself first.
You have to give to yourself first.
Otherwise you have nothing to give away.
You will create a vessel for yourself or
your family,
your community and the world and those
three things will not only lead you to a
blessed life.
I stand as a witness.
My life is so blessed I can't even take
it in.
Sometimes
it will leave you not just to a a gifted
life and a rewarding life that fills you
up,
but a sweet life.
That's what you want.
You want the sweetness.
You want it to be so sweet so that even
when the storms come and they will,
you'll know this too shall pass.
This too shall pass.
The storm is passing over and you shall
not be moved because you know who you
are.
When you can do that,
grace will follow you,
grace and glory,
and when they see you coming,
it Oughta make them proud.
They say it's the click of your heels.
It's the bender yo hair.
It's the palm of your hand.
It's the need for your care because you
are a woman.
You a Spelman,
phenomenally phenomenal class of 2012
thank you.